here tonight at the ACM awards were
through lovely lady on your arm and
expecting how does that feel just great
I thought I was made out of one and now
I'm gonna be out of two so it's a pretty
awesome and we're just gearing up for it
and trying to ask as much advice as
possible and try to be a dad what's some
good advice you've gotten from somebody
um you know it's a very fortunate to
have friends that also tour as much as I
do and have kids Luke and Dirks I've
been talking to a bunch about it and you
know they say don't don't be worried if
you drink six Red Bulls a day it's
natural and just that life that you know
it will become a brand new normal for
you you'll kind of learn to be exhausted
and kind of run off that and but overall
they say it's just the best thing you'll
ever do in your life so really excited
yeah because you're gonna be doubling
the amount of kids doubling email yes
ma'am now when you are on the road and
toured and stuff like that what have you
learned so far about how to stay in
touch with your family and keep them
close to you know Lauren comes quite a
bit on the road but when she's not you
know we try to talk three or four times
a day and try to get at least one face
time in you know cuz there's there's
times when you go a week without seeing
your spouse and it's a long time but uh
you know she's been out with me a lot
and especially when the kids going we're
going to try to make it way more of a
family ordeal and bring them on the road
and all that good stuff music what can
we expect um you know the new single
came out yesterday called craving you
and and you know the record is just like
the rest that they're just all over the
place and unpredictable and I really
just write what I'm loving at that point
in time and so will see a record
probably later on this summer
[Music]